l'union la lune de miel entre l'opéra de
paris et la télévision un accord est
intervenu entre rolf liebermann
directeur de l'opéra et marcel jullian
président d'antenne 2 pour que douze
spectacles soient retransmis entre avril
1977 et novembre 1978 les
téléspectateurs d'antenne 2 pourront
donc assister aux contes d'hoffmann à la
flûte enchantée a agi seul roméo
juliette c'est le secrétaire d'état à la
culture qui a mené les négociations
j'ai usé de toute la persuasion pour
disposer pour que les choses se
débloquent
elle paraissait bloqués je crois que
rien n'est plus important que cette très
large diffusion
d'autant plus que chacun sait que les
grandes institutions qui sont à paris
coûte cher que l'ensemble des
contribuables
participent et qu'il est donc de ce
strict point de vue tout à fait normal
qu'ils aient une diffusion au bénéfice
du plus grand nombre mais ce n'est pas
seulement cet aspect là qu'il faut
retenir
je crois qu'il est extrêmement important
partout on écoute on voit on lise et on
soit largement tape renier situation de
recevoir ce qui existe de meilleurs et
l'opéra de paris et ceux qui existent
meilleurs au monde dans son journal
madame giroux a également annoncé
qu'elle relançait l'opéra studio c'est à
dire une école de formation pour les
artistes lyriques et qui grâce à un
accord passé aujourd'hui justement avec
l'opéra de paris
eh bien ils pourront se produire dans un
spectacle avec les choeurs et orchestre
de l'opéra